el 16 de septiembre maxamín y muere en
el hospital por supuestamente un paro
cardíaco puede ser detenida tres días
antes por la policía de la moral bajo el
pretexto de camini llevaba mal colocado
el velo islámico un informe de la
Organización de Medicina forense negó
que a Minnie muriera por golpes
achacando su fallecimiento a una
enfermedad cerebral algo que tanto la
familia de la joven de 22 años como
expertos y testigos contradicen el 17 de
septiembre durante el funeral de la
joven en el kurdistán iraní estalló la
rabia e iniciaron las primeras protestas
en algunas localidades lideradas por las
mujeres y jóvenes pronto la indignación
se extendió a todo el país bajo el lema
mujer vida y Libertad las jóvenes
quemaban sus velos en las calles a la
vez que aumentaba la brutal represión de
las fuerzas estatales que según la
organización de Derechos Humanos Irán
Human Rights deja ya más de 200 muertos
y miles de heridos un número muy
superior al admitido por el régimen
iraní pronto activistas y la diáspora
iraní en el exterior organizaron
protestas en otras partes del con
personalidades públicas y políticas
cortándose el cabello como símbolo de
solidaridad con las mujeres iraníes en
respuesta al régimen iraní cortó las
comunicaciones y el internet llevó a
cabo detenciones de periodistas los
teócratas iraníes en el poder acusaron a
Estados Unidos y Israel de dirigir una
política fallida de desestabilización un
mes después de su muerte la revolución
del hillab continuó aguantando el pulso
de la represión de las autoridades de la
República islámica de Irán extendiendo
su reclamos no solo contra la
obligatoriedad del velo los derechos de
las mujeres sino para exigir el fin del
autoritario régimen y la caída de la
cúpula